hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
today we're going to look at how a girl
grew up with no money lives with her
eight siblings in a small apartment and
she would go on to be the only woman
named to Time Magazine's most
influential business people of the
century this is a story of Estee Lauder
and a top three lessons that you can
learn from her success Estee Lauder was
born in Queens New York the daughter of
Gary and Jewish immigrants most of her
childhood was spent helping her parents
make ends meet by working at the
family's hardware store as she grew up
she met Joseph Lauder a textile salesman
who she married and moved to Manhattan
with after the birth of her first child
Lauder didn't want to give up her
professional career and experimented
different ingredients to create a
skincare cream for women
she began out of her kitchen and after a
year of hard work got her big break Saks
Fifth Avenue agreed to carry her product
and it sold out within two days of it
being put on the shelves after 50-plus
year to the top of her game Estee Lauder
became the only woman on Time magazine's
list of the 20 most influential business
geniuses of the century in 2009 at state
ladder companies had over 7 billion
dollars in revenue almost 30 thousand
employees and it all began at a crowded
kitchen table
by starting from her kitchen table and
by never giving up estee lauder was able
to become the most influential business
genius of the 20th century to help you
overcome your obstacles and grow your
business
here are three action items that you can
learn from estée lauder action um number
one don't stop at the first note being
an entrepreneur means you're going to
get a lot of rejection whether it's
friends and family telling you that your
idea will never be successful or
prospects and customers telling you they
don't want to buy from you you'll get a
lot of notes successful entrepreneurs
pick themselves back up after rejection
and keep improving their products and
messaging until they get to a yes Lauda
was known for her unwavering persistence
when she was trying to expand her
European market she arranged a meeting
with a manager of galleries lafayette
Europe's largest department store when a
manager said no she accidentally spilled
her perfume samples on the floor and the
store customers started asking how they
could buy some of the fragrance the
manager had to give her a contract
according to Lauder I have never worked
a day in my life without selling if I
believe in something I sell it and I
sell it hard if you have a goal if you
want to be successful if you really want
to do it and become another estee lauder
you've got to work hard you've got to
stick to it and you've got to believe in
what you're doing
Akshat item number to love what you do
any successful entrepreneur will tell
you that one of the keys to their
success is that they love what they do
when you really love your business you
not only enjoy it more but you put the
kind of time and energy and that's
needed for a company to take off you see
what the details constantly improve your
offering not just because it'll make you
money but because you love doing it
lahter loved her product so much that
she paid attention to every little
detail when she got her first deal with
saxis Avenue she stood at the entrance
door for an entire week and watched the
women come in nine times out of ten the
first place her eyes would wander would
be to the right not to the left not
straight ahead so she asked for her
product we placed on the right
according to Lauder I love my product I
love to touch the creams smell them look
at them carry them with me a person has
to love her harvest if she is to expect
others to love it
action item number three sell sell sell
not all entrepreneurs and natural
salespeople but you have to learn how to
sell if you want to build a business of
any significant size more entrepreneurs
fail because they can't sell rather than
them not having a good product or
service
when Lada was first getting started she
didn't have money to spend on
advertising and promotions so she
invested her time into product demos she
began at salons hotels subway stations
and even people on the street offering
them a free makeover and the chance to
buy her products she eventually moved
the sell to the big department stores
but it all began on a $0 budget and her
grinding out sale after sale
according to Lauder if you put the
product into the customers hands it will
speak for itself if it's something of
quality if you don't sell it's not the
product that's wrong it's you
so remember don't stop at the first note
love what you do and sell sell sell to
finish this video I wanted to share one
my favorite true stories about Estee
Lauder and some of her top quotes one
slaughter built up enough money to start
a marketing campaign
she went to various advertising agencies
all turned her down because a company
was too small with only $50,000 as
friend she used her entire budget on
samples that she would send out as
direct mail campaigns and free gifts
with purchases it proved to be a
successful move and she changed the way
beauty products were marketed
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the masters if you
enjoyed please give the video a thumbs
up I'd also love to hear your thoughts
if you want to leave a comment below and
stay tuned for the next episode